In researching IGG flu sensitivity tests, I was surprised to see a lot of medical people
including the American Academy of Technology and Immunology stated that there's not enough
respectable research supporting the increased IGG levels that equal sensitivity.
One site suggested studies showing that IGG levels actually increase this allergy sensitivity
as a result, and that IGG levels only indicate exposure to a substance, not sensitivity to it.
How do these criticisms of IGG panels
better resolved in your mind so that you are recommending Syrex testing? So Syrex is a lab that I
recommend for food sensitivity testing and antibody testing to self-tissues and to diagnose food
sensitivity and self-antibiotis. That means you have a lot over the business.
So first of all, I don't give a lot of faith to any of these American Academy anything
because they're all governed by money. But there are tests, there are possibly
studies that show these kind of things. The reason why I like Syrex testing is a test for IGG,
IGG are the IGG antibodies, not just IGG, also a test for cooked and raw foods.
Also, I have on the autoimmune course. I think it's module one or two more details
in what Syrex tests for. The other cytotoxic testing for food allergies that is on the market is
what is called MRT testing mediator release testing. What is the Alcat test that's probably
the most positive. That's an antigen leukocyte antibody test. It was called an LRA test,
a leukocyte response test. All of these basically measure non-specific cell size changes.
Actually, most of these tests are banned in some states because they're highly unreliable.
You can literally run a person, a lab on a person, and then send it in, you'll take blood samples
and send it in two different times, and you can get two different results. It's very poor
reproducibility. Antibody testing isn't perfect, though, I will say. I don't think, like I've said,
maybe a thousand times, that there is no perfect test. There's all sorts of reasons a person
can end up with antibodies to different foods. Those antibodies can dissipate over time, so you
could run an antibody test on yourself, and you change your diet. A month later, you run another
antibody test, and it can change. Some for the good, we need antibodies to go down and some for the
bad. We need some antibodies to go up. When you run an antibody test, like a Cyrex, let's say,
array 10, which tests for a hundred different foods, cooked in raw, different foods, different foods,
different foods, different foods, substances that would be found in foods that could cause reactions
to your gut, and you have a lot of reactions to different foods. The treatment plan is not
to simply remove those foods. The treatment plan is to feel the gut. Sometimes, when you see
antibodies to different foods, it's really a sign that, boy, I really need to increase my digestive
enzymes with my foods. I'm developing antibodies to XYZ food because it's not digesting well. For
instance, if you have a lot of in the nuts category, if you have a lot of antibodies to the different
nuts, nuts are difficult to digest, and if you've got a lot of antibodies so that, that gives you a
clinical plural that I probably am deficient in digestive enzymes, at least when I'm eating nuts,
that is my issue. So if I just started that, those antibodies would go away at a retest.
So it's not a just a matter of boy, I have to eliminate these 20 foods completely, though I do suggest
you do cut back or eliminate those, especially the ones that are in the red positive on a Cyrex panel.
To calm down the gut, you've got to work at the same time to heal the gut. So whenever you have
antibodies to food, that's an abnormal response. You should never develop antibodies to food. So why
does a person develop antibodies to food? Well, primarily, it's because you have a damaged gut
border. The cells of the gut, the epithelial cells of the gut, should be close together. Those are
called tight junctions where they come in contact. The cells come in contact with one another. And that
tight junction can be damaged usually because of, you know, you're exposed to chemicals and
drugs, antibiotics. Glyphosate is a major player in that. Anything that gets in your gut, that's
going to cause an inflammatory response because it's not supposed to be there because it's a poison.
Can damage the epithelial cells? Can weaken the tight junctions? It's an enzyme bond that holds
those together. Those can break down. Those tight junctions can spread apart. And then foods get across
the gut wall that never should have got across the gut wall. What do you mean? Well, when you eat a,
let's say, I'm going to eat a liba bean, okay? That's that protein. It's got fiber in it. Other
macrodutrients. But macrodutrients are broken down into microdutrients. So a protein is a long
chain of amino acids. So a amino acid is one substance and they're chained together, bonded together. So
think of a protein as a, as a pearl necklace of an amino acids. Well, you don't absorb the entire
pearl necklace of an amino acids if you did, you really got a really unhealthy gut because you have to be,
you know, quite widespread of that tight junction for that to get across the gut membrane. If you did,
then you would actually develop antibodies against that protein in your bloodstream because what
remember, I explained what the immune system does. You're at this TH1 response,
trying to kill things that aren't supposed to be their pathogens. If I can't kill it, you'll fire
a TH2 response, a B cell response. What's the purpose of that is to make antibodies against that pathogen?
Well, if there's things in the bloodstream like proteins that are being protein,
that never should have been there in the first place because it should have got broken down,
that giant pearl necklace should have been snipped up down to the maximum of two little proteins,
two little, if pearl beads, that's called a dipeptide. And most of the time down to a single peptide,
we needed a single amino acid, then it could cross the blood through natural beads,
not through a broken blood, blood got barrier, but naturally absorbed into the bloodstream through
the gut, through proper channels. And then your body takes those amino acids and in the cells,
intercellurally, you create new proteins that your body needs to create. So you take proteins
from foods, aliamabee, you snip it down by the use of enzymes in the gut, snip down to either
dipeptides or a single amino acid, then that naturally crosses the gut border into the bloodstream,
it goes into the cells and then your cells turn it into whatever protein,
aka, enzyme is needed to do cellular function, to build tissue, to build muscle, to do all these
different things that you need proteins to do, one of them to stimulate a good T cell immune
response for you to kill cancer cells. Problem is if you have damaged gut border, then things are
getting across the gut border in larger forms than should ever have gotten through in other peptides,
meaning proteins that are broken down into 15 chain peptides, 22 chain peptides, 28 chain peptides,
getting across the gut border, then your immune system is going, what in the world is that?
Let's kill it. Well, can you kill a peptide of a protein? No, it's not living. So then you fire a
B cell response, you create antibodies against that thing. What is it? What is the antibody going to do?
It's just tagging it. So every time now that antibody is circulating in your bloodstream, every time
that antibody is eliciting in response to an antigen, it's going to fire in immune response,
it's going to fire in this inflammatory response and you begin systemic inflammation.
Worse, those antibodies are also screened into the lumen of the gut so that when that peptide,
now you know, you eat a lot of it again, now you fire in immune response against the peptides
in the gut, even if you are trying to break it down healthfully, you're firing this immune response
in your gut and you're causing an inflammatory response in the gut, which is this huge negative cycle,
you got more inflammation in the gut, damaged the gut lighting even more and this whole negative
cycle creates, you know, more problems. So what do you do? Well, you do things to heal the gut.
Well, how do you do that? When you're trying to heal the gut, you start from the top down. You
make sure you're chewing your food. You make sure you have proper saliva because saliva, you know,
you have enzymes in saliva, the talent and enzymes to break down, primarily carbohydrates,
goes down into your stomach, what does your stomach need? Deeds HCl, you don't have enzymes in your
stomach, primarily it's mainly hydrochloric acid to break down proteins, carbohydrates, but fast,
mainly proteins. If you don't have proper HCl production, you're going to cause just a cascade
of problems. Food's going to go into your small intestine very partially digested. It's going to
put so much stress on your pain, Chris. A lot of theories that that is a major cause of
pain, create a cancer increase over the last few decades. It goes into their improperly
digested, put so much stress on your pain, Chris. Once your pain, Chris, do two things,
makes insulin for your blood, but also makes digestive enzymes that's created in through the common
bile duct into the duodenum to break down your food in your gut. It's hyper stress, totally
breaking it down part way, you already have a damaged gut, so things are crossied as peptides,
not as dipeptides or single amino acids, and all that cascade that I just got done talking about
happens, and now you're about your strength. So how do you feel it from the top down? You're going to
make sure you have HCl proper digested enzymes, proper digested enzymes, proper digested enzymes.
I'll break that down. You can heal your gut through other nutrients that I listed that course
about healing. You've got different things, egoceride, licorice, okra, that's where we with
cancer patients, we don't want to use glutamine, glutamine can be helpful to help heal your gut.
But there's a bunch of different things in our product, clear GI that could help heal,
they've got slippery L, other things that could be really got healing products.
A lot of things. So how do you test for anything? How do you test for it? You do antibody testing,
so you want to get a good test, the test, not just IgG, but IgM and IgA,
well, the Syrex-10 test for IgG and IgA, the Syrex-2 test for IgG, IgM and IgA,
so you're testing for these things as best as you possibly can. What if I don't want to do the test?
What if I don't have money to do the test? Well, let's just start eliminating things in your diet,
trying to have a rotational diet, trying to clean up your body, trying to decrease the inflammation,
do the other steps that you could do. We have patients that I can't afford to do this,
all this testing, that's okay, just start doing the things that you can do, not everybody can do
the testing, just do what you can do, but still by far Syrex-Labs is the best testing for this,
just by a bit.